[Musique]
m
en voilà bourgeois sauvage est
désagréable ordinairement les vieux
garçons c'était farceur pas celui-là il
vit tout seul dans des endroits noir
comme as colimaçons
dans ce moment il se rase en se rasant
il se coupe pour arrêter le sang il
serre ses toiles d'araignées ils en
trouvent pas alors il vous donne
et puis la nôtre tique quand il a fini
sa barre il va se recoucher il se lève
tard très tard afin dit-il de contempler
moi longtemps ses semblables tiens à
propos de semblable j'ai oublié
d'acheter du mouron pour le sera à
monsieur le sol être qu'il aime ici bas
je vais lui donner du sucre
à
ces lui il sole
il craint gens reconnaissent alassane
est ma foi gare la sauce jeu masson
beaucoup de lier m'a dit que sera ce
soir tout près ce rasoir ne coupe pas
nous on veut que j'aime le genre humain
pitié pitié les hommes et j'ai dans le
nez
tout en ce moment les commensaux je vole
et fourberie exemple hier ce soit à
trois pattes chez moi on me fais mon
mouchoir genre temps dans un magasin
pour en acheter un autre il y avait
écrit sur la devanture un glee show
spock 1
et on ne parlait que le français
et on veut que j'aime le genre humain
non tous les hommes en rouge dans les
faux bail
aussi j'ai conçu un vaste dessein j'ai
des amis des canal d'amis sous prétexte
que c'est toujours lui m'a fait vont
venir m'offrir l'envi en hauteur au cij
d'un ménage une petite surprise à août
une fête puis 15 avec des gâteaux de
l'époque
et des rafraîchissements frelaté comme
le compliment à binic je crains pas
photo je l'écris des toutes les deux sur
la scène de crime à ce film étrange ou
charge
et quand ils seront partis
je désinfecte aurait là par tonne
je m'en fera 10 danses costumes 1
j'ai mal dormi
j'ai fait des cauchemars atroce
gérer dès que j'en pensais à nos terres
les trois avouent y voit un point
c'est la plus ultime tournante
je reconnais bien là mise en forme des
hommes n'avaient cette porte sud dont je
suis client une empreinte de quatre ou
cinquième
avec mon portefeuille que j'ai égaré
dans l'appartement je ne sais joue un
portefeuille nourri de 4 billets de 1000
da je me suis paris un cigare qu'on ne
rapporterait pas eh ben j'ai gagné
triste
midi libre a couché
non auparavant jean à vue de mettre tous
les domestiques à la porte
les épices un jour c'est trop fois fini
mieux après ce qu'on a dit à droite
le mnr demeure au point
regarde moi comment tu trouves tu ce
matin monsieur est frais comme une rose
je suis jaune je suis fan et je suis
loupé attend misérable surface mais
monsieur jacques hors
frais aux mois
on veut que j'aime le genre à l'autre
approche vous demi après il a l'air de
bonne humeur bastien tu fais un honnête
homme un homme honnête regarde moi
répond moi franchement si je me marre
des moitiés que je serai à non monsieur
pourquoi la dame parce que parce que
monsieur et si aimable trading les
flatter guerre mon ami en me promenant
le jardin des plantes j'ai laissé tomber
d'épingler dans la peau de l'ours martin
va me lâcher
moi oui je te défendre m dt ici son
épingle alors vous me chasser je ne
chasse pas t'en vas chercher une épingle
obama prenait cette banderille est
j'éprouve le besoin de cause aux salles
et qu'elle
reprenne est
nette je t'ai fait venir pour te dire
que je ne faisais pas un cas énorme de
toi comment un tu voles mon sucre tu te
plantes en déconfiture et tu veux
fabrique des filets ovum madère avec de
la piquer par exemple de ne pas contrer
ça me fait plaisir aussi soto gari un
bon service toujours messier bien qu'on
ne fait pas bon photographe pour avoir
entré deux mois l'échantillon de tous
les vices de toutes les raffineries et
si par hasard j'avais la faiblesse
d'abolir de croire à la bonne foi et ben
tu serais là doit revoir pour m'éclairer
comme un texte d'accord avec valve n'a
pas construit d'être que j'avais à dire
maintenant retournes à ta cuisine
reprendre le cours de son exploitation
et ya ces paroles cet homme là aussi la
place était pas si bonnes mais qui
ébranle coucher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sabri corner que le diable l'emporté
bonjour serhani
nous le 4 mars
nous avons reçu votre lettre
d'invitation pour ce soir on dit que ce
sera charmant oui je crois dur en
surprises à quelles heures à minuit
quand les flandriens l'apport thouars
c'est délicieux madame caussenard ce
fait une faible somme totale que fais tu
te fait savez vous qu'elle est très
jolie votre femme mais pas mal pas mal
autant dire que le rap us haute à la
témérité cieux année le push tes cheveux
et tel vertueuse
dit il ça vous plaisantez foutu nous
avons énormément de femmes qui ne sont
pas vertueuse appareils non en chine
pourquoi n'est-il ça auriez-vous après
quelques journaux si je le savais je
vous le dis
ce serait un ami d'un véritable ami ah
ah ah ah ce bon chiffre n'est que je
suis donc content de vous revoir il
caresse d'un témoin de quelque chose à
propos j'ai compter sur vous pour me
rendre un petit service
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de 30 mille francs pour un
mois figurez vous que j'ai découvert ce
matin un cheval qui vaut de l'or je
compte le faire courir à chantilly mais
dans ce moment je ne suis pas en argent
comptant et j'ai pensé à vous
[Musique]
aulas
amitié nous lie
[Musique]
vous seriez vous ses accents
un
habit cède pas
lui
on
retourne veut dans tous les tons
et surtout
pour les mots répond
l'image me semble joli
mais mon rôle est très affligeant
car moi je
recevrai la plume
est
ce vraiment
marchons
à
moi je cesserai la pluie
est
ce
[Musique]
oh
les hommes
[Musique]
répondez pas franchement comment me
trouvez vous ce matin pauvre homme il se
frappe voulez vous que je vous parle
france oui ça doit
vous est vrai comme un jeunot et par
bercy canaille canin allez-vous la c4
est là donc j'attends de rentrer au rock
détente une heure merci vous êtes ça
mais qu'elles me tenez vous vivrez
sentant abandonnés à leur table s'entend
pour 4000 francs
cada cana
brunette mathieu jeu coquelin reviendra
dans une heure puis reims strasbourg
bien monsieur
tanner
a strasbourg et bâle sa soirée et bon
joueur chiffres les ouvriers
comment monsieur mashabane vous entrez
dans le salon avec vous sauf et ouais si
bordeaux j'ai mes chevaux rio
[Musique]
ont fait fortune à sa manière c'est à
qui sera le plus malin
ouais c'est dans l'eau de la rivière que
je veux faire mon chemin
à l'eau ce
refrain de
hanau au lot un homme comme moi porte à
la ronde
chez riches et pauvres c'est certain
et aux gens fournit à tous
le monde
jean fournit même on a choisi
l on sait enfin
mieux
anon
au
[Musique]
kenya c'était bien parti eh ben vous
voulez voyons et je veux parler au monde
joueurs pour des affaires et par un
secret qu'est ce que c'est mais voilà je
suis venu pour lui dire et lui dit pères
et mères elles coulaient toujours le son
le pont neuf
aucune tête et vous ne verrez pas pour
voir leurs idoles
moi je vois dans les veillées
qu'est ce que c'est que cet animal est
simple turbo
toi qui m'avait ce matin mais si elle me
dit mais aussi vous soyez seigneur
qu'est ce que tu veux il coache 10 pour
mon collègue est perdus c'est chaud là
où tu es comme un test lors des sprints
et
je crois après un portefeuille couleurs
entretenant quatre billets de même
amassé vient de vivre la langue
maintenant j'ai plus rien et vous livrer
vos soins or ça c'est prodigieux que je
veux ton un cigare et nous ont battus
2-1 par ton pseudo toi tu oublies tes
petites les coppens est composée cause
de fouet parce que tu te rapporte le cap
il touche un fortin le nom ces points
chez nous or si ce n'était de la
ferraille mais de l'argent fiche très ça
fait plaisir en apporter pour rien et
c'est pour avoir davantage connu la
petite fille seule tiens tiens tiens
voilà quarante forum meyrin les enfants
de mon vernis sont des zones et 200
francs recul et soeurs il
alors que vous pourriez me tenter et
alors là je vous aplatir est comme une
limande
tel sainte habitations comment
t'appelles-tu méchoui à chaque match je
me suis dit explique bubedra couchepin
calme-toi à 5 à 6 francs je ne sais pas
mentir moi tout ça te mentir tu sais pas
mentir à soi
comme on trouve tu ce matin je vous
trouve et
c'est bien c'est pas lui répondre
franchement si je me mariais crois tu
que je serais tout de suite
salonais tout de suite enfin voilà ça
fait du bien ça rend cause on a raison
de dire que la vérité habitera puis mais
sont les porteurs d'eau elle y restaurer
à deux
causes mois mashabane cause - révoltant
mais des pratiques et qualité je conçois
than fast qui sous écoute pas bon
savoyard on est concerné c'est égal
écoute ma contient gagnes tu as porté
ainsi de l'eau j'étais contemporain et
il gagne de 30 à 31 jours d'un jeu mais
ça suffit pour vivre offre égalité
frugalité écoute moi sommes dépendants
optique
j'ai besoin de l'ami peux-tu devenir le
mien te donnerai 100 francs par jour
logée nourrie saint-flo fiche 3 qu'est
ce que j'aurais avait repéré la vérité
rien que la vérité toute la vérité moi
jamais été de finir au patent que
toutefois d'un ouvrage tu te d'état à
l'affût et des qui paraîtra un monceau
dans cette maison pas du direct sans
pitié kendall des vins et essai et si
c'est vous qui m'ont à des raisons plus
du tir à à mitraille eux alors c'est
prendre du tout ça j'ai convenu
alors l instant vous pouvez peut-être un
filou la ve vous pouvez être furieux on
les traite du fil
il échappe au
continent n'est qu'une supposition d'un
vigile umf lentilles à la porte comme
une écaille dhuizon jamais oui mais j'en
étais à dumont et aiment et pratiquent
tonnes et non décidément j'aime mieux
porter mon art est cruel pacha pas du
tout que je me lit parle parle de nous
ou les paroles d'honneur c'est comme la
neige ça fond de bonnes feuilles j'aime
ce souverain mépris des orbes
petite-nation atteint 3,6 tu as mon soir
face à l'as monaco tient
ailleurs c'est bien sens où vous avez
dit oui et de plus je stipule un forte
dit il simplement on s'est passé en iran
hop là comme ça qui veut ça papa et je
signe autour
de moi non c'est pas que je me méfie
regarde si vous avez bien mis l'essence
où il fait bon venir essayer ici
cet homme jeune
comme un chien qu'on a pas d'enjeu moi
je ne désire plus rien je suis riche
voilà mon bien
maintenant c'est au démontage
voix compte gens aux sottises
hijab le mensonge et bien je viens
d'acheter la franchise mais vrai qu'un
je tiens à ma fortune il faut que je le
dise oui je tiens je la tiens oui je
lève
[Musique]
étienne
haut
de gamme allemand zf net n'est pas comme
dérange quand je suis avec mon ami tu
partes instants après les belles voix
est plus nette que cet homme n'ait plus
à porter tous je viens de les leviers au
bras d'un ami restera à les zones ça
souffle un jour là j'ai joli 4 au bout
il ya combien de ces
écoutes le compte de la cuisinière tout
le sauvant à annaba et je suis français
il m'a dit tu as joué je me délecte de
taille et en
toute amitié
josé pattes le prix du times
il est plein de saveurs vous n'êtes des
comptes
alors pas 3 francs comprend pas il est
recommandé aux montées pot-au-feu 750
santis et francs 50 centimes de
pot-au-feu pilotes il est remonté le
ponant le feu non la viande joue et
légumes car en dessous voulait
différents mais cette fois
elle ne prenait pas augmenter le nombre
y ont foulé j'étais chez la massonne
vous l'avez payé france vous taisez vous
tombez non non pour promouvoir les
braves hommes et femmes et proclame
celle ci noces
quelle admirable buisson à celle d'un
côté un vérité c'est moi de l'autre le
mensonge et siphonné au milieu calme et
sauveur
c'est égal un mail à payer que sens où
il est je dirais pourquoi monsieur bah
ça va tu as été gigantesque lui a été
promis je taxe d'abattage bat après je
vais bien m'habiller mais l'a payé de
chant source
cet arbre une vraie koch contrite fait
l'autre ton corps seront tues
mais je vais revenir bien vite
ceux-là fabien la
râpée
seul et armé créé qui me to hell
pourrais me tromper
mais s'il revient doit bien vite pour
mieux encore
être plus
sereine dans cet avenir y croire que je
veux
mon pays
kim sang hyde ont bien fait que je
n'irais pas le rattraper
[Musique]
je comptais
bien vite
je ne crois pas
[Musique]
et je veux bien m'habiller mais il a
payé de chansons
sera sympa le divorce puis quel bonheur
pour mon foyer il a découvert la danse
de lance de son panier
approche moins d'enfants à bros
alors nous filent août on l'a mené à
papa siphonnaient monsieur je vais vous
dire la vérité la vérité ou je te mau
vous m'avez dit pour la soierie petit
peu le rouge voit bien qu aux yeux de me
renvoyer je m'en garderais c'est que je
suis donné deux filles au moins
au cas tu as la caisse d'epargne j'ai
deux mille francs incessamment tu gagnes
300 francs par an et une un bon service
depuis huit mois au top et intime le
résultat était plat tueur j'ai fait un
héritage amérique
tiens la barre pour toi j'aime tes mots
c'est moche au tdp vous je vois bien que
monsieur manque de confiance en moi
pensions
conscient que vous lacombe lui ça non ah
si tu ne ruinerait c'est pas possible il
a eu un coup de marteau alors as-tu bien
exécuté mes ordres pour ce soir oui mais
si les sirops sont ils bien mauvais bien
tourner bien être oui mais yotov de ses
chers amis et les gâteaux ils ont huit
jours ou dans ce ton peu je journée et
le violet j'ai pas mis de riz il est
dans monsieur métais ce n'est pas bien
at the moon over à l'hôte a haussé vieux
20 h jeudi de la moutarde eux et quant
aux bougies de la soirée monsieur que
tout ça peut faire puisque tu me le
contrat comme de la bougie un titre
landes titre i bond à 2 petit courgain
mashabane telles tentatives manquées
ouais mais c'est votre papier je pense
que la saleuse john hall tamoul de la
garde nationale qui fait monsieur
chiffonnette gare de demain à molières
de clichy et portier qui lui répond je
n'ai plus si c'était contre je suis
connu la traitant monde puisse venir si
qui me serait maladroit s'habiller
théâtre de genève beauté il n'a pas
voulu la révéler alors ça me regarde de
bob chalgham le chargeur alors je suis
coluche et de ses jardins dorment et
tokpa me même si crier côté les films et
maintenez tombiez lehto billets car
c'est pour demain merci bien obligé
comme la tarte me
fait pas plaisir au niveau tu ne crois
pas que c'est moi qui avait rendu au
port comme un mensonge
au mot son
certainement certainement temps qu'il a
un tantinet loin vous bah oui ma maladie
les familles
[Musique]
assisteront ensuite
à rio ave prier et mes loisirs
6 1
comme si finalement
cet avis tient sûrement un peu la bouche
de monchy
même envier comme les mauvaises bien ça
va bien pour contrebande pas salon on te
demande pas ça ils ne sont que je ne
suis pas plus mal fait de nous huawei et
tapas demande est un tas de gens mais
plus maintenant à terme les communes
situées mais ça va de la banlieue ça
madame temps voilà ce dont tu sois aussi
que je suis franc
de chercher des rues de là
je crois entre nous il manque un peu de
goût non
messieurs voilà si madame comme meneur
qui demande à vous parler en secret le
quota de si belles formes dans mon
héritage je suis fâché de ne pas avoir
ma perruque 9 enfin vers près oui
messieurs entre et madame entrée modes
de jeu ne reste qu à l est encore plus
substantielle
et vous dépensez ma démarche madame je
pense que votre démarche est celle d'une
gazelle c'est à dire que vous la trouvez
les jeunes moins deux mois et vous avez
raison osez me présenter chez vous jeune
homme j'ai un garçon somme à l'absence
d'un mari le plus beau cortège une femme
chez un gars ou dans des bulles ou si
vous allez dire que je suis bien
discrète mais hp de grâce vous avez vu
monsieur coq noir ce matin j ai vous a
je crois par les noms d'emprunt et bien
pour les cas plus fort soyons froid
c'est une carotte fectivement d'alain
effectivement nous allons parler
vaguement que ceux-ci mandatement à
dippach bleus et je suis venu à son insu
dans l'est en catimini en catimini
qu'est ce qu'il a
vous pourrez y est comme je n'avale vous
supplier le moment je n'ai pas allumé
ses 4000 vélos à
ba1 d'un de nouveau dans la peine de
vous asseoir je redeviens bandits
mais prenez ont refusé ce pauvre connard
et romuald shepley un cruel mais pour
vous être agréable
à tous non j'ai tort de vous dire mais
bon mari possède à travers qu'on se
livreraient thi loan qu
il adore il y donne la triche moi ces
vilaines petites créatures sont gars qui
vous êtes par thème oui monsieur
parce qu'il s'agit dans son écurie il y
en a fait son salut son cabinet gravats
sont benoît et sa chambre à coucher tard
je dois vivre dans le fumier comme un
melon phi phi phi phi est encore fi
gsm a posé des prix d'as ou lui donner
une âme et renens j'ai dessiné un
cachemire et bien et bien de se contenir
cette année à toi n'est pour vos martyrs
de l'équitation cependant je ne voudrais
pas que cette cette passion leur finale
le ruine or je comprends ce subjonctif
c'est le subjonctif d'un ange à qui on a
refusé un cas celui
ci monsieur c'est bien convenu vous ne
prêteraient pas c'est frau soyez sans
crainte d'ailleurs puis-je refuser
quelque chose à une femme à se
déboutonner employés ne seront mieux
pour cause il s'est même attiré vers
simon harris ne ment pas tout de suite
le sénat compte en appeler se profile
byzantin ce poney qu'est ce que je
raconte pas te connais
pour
nous avec ces cieux faute à l'amande
douce autre souhait mais c'est souvent
le seul qui ce mot sera pour eux
fabuleux car tu veux pas
vous mais de ce côté-là
d'amour
mon dieu nous à vous que je réponde me
plaindre la nature la patrouille arte
amont et à
l'apéritif les voit pas du tout connaît
pas vrai si maintenant elle cinéma si
les moeurs des marais
carnaval seulement pour me mettre en
garde française j'espère vous ne croyez
pas un mot à dire monsieur compter sur
la discrétion matin ce matin là c'est
bien pour 4
anciennes et monsieur papa
superbe ici ne trouve ici sa posture il
est d'une jalousie monsieur thuram toi
brunette qui compte ni je suis pas à ma
part égale aux devantures cette
phrase au petit oiseau les pompiers
dimanche ce soit sur n'oublie pas tes
réponses et bonjour j venait
pas du tout pas du tout le jeu je
sortais je sortais d'un essor j'ai bien
sûr chez les catholiques prendre je vous
ai parlé à mon dieu et sa femme qui m'a
fait promettre mais là on l'a dit j'en
suis désolé mais c'est un rentrée sur
laquelle je comptais enfin de pas
d'argent pas d'argent on a beau frère
qui y vivent aussi
faux nez on croyait montpon coq n'a que
si j'avais cette somme je serai heureux
home est bien heureux de pouvoir vous
l'offrir on est en crise et sa
subalterne ignore népal beckett et
vérité c'est qu'il me reste cinq coups
francs pour dîner aidera mois avait
essuyé le cavalier en collectif le plus
important j'oubliais à d'oublier
mais ça mais ça c'est la grève mais
c'est la peste cet auvergnat
tennis et rami tenue voilà l'état tenus
francs à mon avis que de remerciement
n'y a pas de coin adieu attendons se
sont pressés tiens tu extraordinaire
système de micro
mathis a atteint cette étape c'est une
tablette ont subi des dégâts le jazz ça
ça suffit ce que c'est que ça eh bien
écoutez je ne voudrais pas dire de
bêtises mais je crois bien que c'est du
nombre et avec lui c'est un cadeau que
je viens de faire à ma nièce kanna riez
pas le premier drone ou non il faut
prendre des points là des membres de la
cei c'est l'ombre elle dit avec un
chapeau violet et allait bien mais
quelque chose lui je garde ça sera le
même que tout est là le bourgeois ils
viennent les
yeux
doux à cette date je vais vous expliquer
dans toi car tu dis la vérité toi avec
toujours il n'ya pas ml c'est bien cette
amnésie ému mais je sais pas bien où ce
qu'elle est passée où je respire tu
concevoir et s'y voient même temps que
n'a pas ce moment où elle
passait peu de sortir de l'avion
monsieur rendez moi ma femme après le
goudron et
les
paumés
ah oui
c'est quoi ça que tu sors
[Musique]
et
mon dieu si jamais le temps de
hauteville fraude c'est
dans doute et sans
rentrer
[Musique]
le firent un effet répulsif
acier maintenant brunette suis
intelligente et ruine les partis créés
n'y avait rien de rien adieu ma nièce
prat mary embrasse comme des bustes de
prendre ton mari et aimerait peut voter
pour 2008 en restons à rivière ouelle
avec des correspondants et
c'est mon ombre est mal à
gagner sinon c'est pas ma femme et it or
selon la même sans
le traiter beaucoup plus bleu mais il
ya là un mystère je le découvrirai ya
moyen dans 5 minutes vient me rejoindre
au café en face enfin pour toi
village à moux
j'avais tort je le reconnais
soupçonné un ami ce bon chiffre mais je
vous aurais tu es d'abord au mollet
il a pas les adieux attente au toit dans
cinq minutes on y sera
s'ils sont avec mystère et sans but et
sans
éclat
bientôt je sauvais j'espère
faire parler ses taux vergne un
[Musique]
cap
sp
éclat
qui n'est pas si j'ai deux frères
fait mentir nous seigneur
je convaincu c'est un mystère
mais je ne m'explique pas pourquoi l'on
m'a sur la terre
introduit des sceaux dernière
je veux
s'appelle mystère ne veut
explorer
je vais pas plonger sur la sphère
du zoo
[Musique]
doivent fiche mal tant radcliffe là où
il est trois chiffres en francs mais
plutôt connaît lui l'idole et je
préférais fonds au des deux sociétés
pour la destruction des animaux
nuisibles y compris les porteurs d'eau
directement des pour neuf ans 3 6 9 à sa
volonté par la mienne sens je suis dans
la position de la au cou
d'une statue du louvre
dans la position de la au camp avec un
auvergnat qui le serpent autour du cou
qui détrône étouffe alors comment faire
pour le renvoyer dans ses salles
montagne dans son savoyard depuis de dos
je conçois un vaste dessein
une idée machiavélique
mais tellement m'achever lis que je
n'ose pas me la confier à maintenant
si je pouvais trouver un nom assez déçus
pour 8 mètres et lui dire
brunette prenez
l ai trouvée honnête tu as fait un coup
de maître tout à l'heure j'étais aussi
bon gré dans le mois da je dois avoir
quelque chose de méphistophélès tic dans
l'oeil il vous a appris quelque chose
dans l'air qu'elle est bête comment
trouves-tu le petit de reuver reignac je
me suis procuré ce matin mais ça va mais
dames messieurs je le trouve belle entre
bret il faut croiser les races j'en veux
te le bébé en marquage mois
auparavant à une condition mais qu'elle
parle on a une seule condition le vous
n'êtes tual et of de ses 17 de ses parts
au don phobie le répertoire du théâtre
français éditions dabo 37 volume très
mal imprimés c'était mon frère elle a
new moore ça me gêne d'amélioration ces
démos femelles sur le type de la
fourberie et de la duplicité palmer
elles ont été inventées pour tendre des
pièges des traquenards deux ans à puce
aux hommes assez sain pour se laisser
prendre alors tous parole et bien si toi
prix des droits que j'estime assez pour
te mettre au rang de cette délicieuse
cantine de ces charmantes et frottez je
te donnais la mission de conduire ces
primitifs macha voile dans le chemin que
tu parcours si noble mort si surtout
chargés de l'année les insultes crème
fouettée que tu possèdes en mai
permettant aux jeunes téméraires je
continue si je te donnais un homme franc
droit francs annie drop ami de la vérité
pour en faire un moteur bref si je te
confier un au verglas te sens-tu ma
force de me rendre à gaston un gars
score d'un monsieur je tâcherai up face
à vannes et à toi mais je te répète
déteint sur lui la mignonne
en local un menteur
va ma table est ce ta fortune est
assurée de 9 ans le talent un moteur
flat un
brh primaire
je suis machiavélique
nettoie la puisaye mamie
d'apprendre a menti en voilà une drôle
d'idée entièrement ces choses là ça
s'apprend pas ça vient tout seul
il m'a promis 20 francs pour ce soir et
ce à deux chiffres et
ils ne me voient pas
c'est vous mêmes les plus délétères
quel dommage
parce qu'on est là a ajouté le la mais
nous avaient pas mes attentes et je vais
vous donner du poulet alors gardez le
mot poulet cependant tous les compagnies
sont assoupis qu'on fait payer diplôme
mais certains fans s'étaient pas pour me
mettre dans ma poche et alors là où
lorsque vous l'avez mis en quel dommage
a su progresser mais pour les
rafraîchissements comment vous dites ça
mais oui monsieur chiffonnait il est si
drôle voulait donner des sirops tournée
mais moi je veux pas que sa maison passe
pour une cassine alors j'ai gagné sur le
poulet pour acheter des sirops en fiche
trash eh bien ça
assez honnête ça devrait commander mais
où est né mademoiselle plus il est faux
je vous en bref c'est pas honnête de
s'embrasser quand on se connaît pas
beaucoup il y viendra elle est bien
connue chez moi beaucoup investi wen au
tac cousin qui m'a piqué ont droit oui
oui je joue et que je peux garder avec
passif barredo et c'est tout comme si la
peau de lapin
ces graisses ou yens et ses petits
petons remplacer il est bien temps
suis-je prouver ni ce que je vaux l'a
dit toujours je vous écoute
je dirais que je vous aime da
allons donc permettez je tourne
tout témoin nommé probité ou ce n'est
pas que je vous blâme
vous aimez trop la vérité pour jamais
bien-aimée ou une femme
[Musique]
écoute et ouvre la fenêtre hallyday vous
avez chaud non c'est un signal si c'est
ça veut dire mais vous êtes fous net
peut-on venir vous voir et qui savent
mon amoureux un madame le garçon du café
d'enfants soit amoureux et quand j'ouvre
la fenêtre ça veut dire vous pouvez
venir vous pouvez vous la fait d'où
vient prier venu tam c'est qu'ils
parlent de m'épouser lui alors et
jean-paul de leurs jumeaux jean paul ii
non un charabia titre au quotidien gérer
mieux tandis que l'autre à gascon c'est
malin et je viendrai malin futé
dernières études et mentalement nous
alors nous renouvelle ce propos si tu as
les roubianais même que la villa qu'est
ce que ça vous fait que je dise la
vérité tiens c'est beaucoup quand je
racaille et quand je me lève je veux pas
d'un mari qui m'a dit mais je voulais
dire est pas alors vous mentir et
au printemps un petit mensonge quand ça
fait mal à personne et que ça rend
service au fait y est c'est l'été mais
c'est vrai que tout ce qu'on me la joue
les si on disait toujours la vérité dans
le monde on passerait sa vie attire des
âges est arrivé c'est possible que
c'était magique je bouge beaucoup mais
il s'en va à
encore accusé ah oui quelques jours par
an si vous vouliez il sera à vous sera
la rentrée dire au client ou ce qu'on
met l'argent dans la cuisine yanina bien
sur quoi au quel dommage ainsi mme aubry
royal là
ça prend pas
alors brunette commencé à apprivoiser un
peu au oui il est souple comme un ipad
et j'y renonce voilà déjà aux prunes est
tout être un vol dans mon estime
7e qu'atteindrait terre par catherine
est morte c'est pas ma faute j'ai tout
fait tout s'est passé presser pour
monsieur la lettre dit dans toi et mon
épingle la voilà messieurs j'en ai pris
une autre ne suis pas dupe
deux lettres une lettre un peu la bête
adam kosa l'iso tout est perdu l'eau
commence tout est perdu
teitel veux dire par là mon mari exige
que je vienne à votre base il a soudoyé
votre verdia qui s'est engagé à 8
désigner la femme qui est piquetage
chibout au corner sacrebleu postis ton
sauvez moi sauvez vous sauvez nous
monsieur cantona aiguise ses pistolets
alors il ya lycées pistolet
sapristi cette histoire et je suis
gentil moi j'ai pas besoin de convaincre
cet animal à mentir vas pas si monsieur
nutritifs à minuit comme heroes la
vérité la vérité j'en suis guéri
la regarde le mais regarde le sportif 5
21me formant qu'il aimait il est l'élu
et
mesure
si je pouvais les venues bougera savoir
alors qu'ils pensent
et après tu liras te promis m ce soir
j'ai fait oui avec connard ici je te
propose une dalle est accusé avec des
petits camarades
les porteurs d'eau ils ont tig et les
porter dans un belge accepte heures ou
demain il ya comme une teigne ce soir j
ai ferme avec même l'accusé moi j'ai pas
besoin de vous j'ai le gascon en face tu
viendras me donner un coup de main mais
qu'est ce qu'on fera la vieille dame il
est complaisant lui pour venir y fera un
mensonge à son bourgeois raymond shaw ou
et le maroc
aux courses de trail course elle m'a dit
j'ai une petite commission à te donner
c'est ce que tu as juste une petite
demi-heure tous travaux tout à main
comme ça ça va tu vas courir tout de
suite tout de suite où ça va le faire
parler ou là tu prendras un billet de
troisième classe c les meilleurs
pour angers avait même ce que c'est
angers c'est un petit peu au-dessus
lanières
n'est ce pas pour nous oui on va piocher
au voyage alors une fois là une fois là
tu demanderas le brigadier dégagement
d'armand et tu vivras ces simples mots
monsieur je n'ai pas de passeport rabat
16 et la vérité au mémorial m'en
voudrais de faire faire à mousson je
veux tu diras aux gendarmes je n'ai pas
le passeport veuillez vous procurer un
logement et je reviendrai au tout de
suite
monsieur madame qu'aucun arrive en tant
que petite est allié à bagnols et fois
c'est immonde qui bouillonne
messieurs et madame kaunas il était
temps otto richard hamilton
je suis ravi de vous recevoir je vous
salue il me salue jours et voici mon
billet mais j'explique de lever revient
souvent j'ai pas dire eh bien je suis à
votre femme que vous me paraissez de le
guetter faut en effet un effet odium
était que les chèvres vaches
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
les avis
sur ses bras
[Musique]
et
je ne fais que passer
et mes amis je voudrais dire qu'il va
falloir sa logique auront des tables de
jeux pour les papas des danses et pour
les demoiselles et des gâteaux de
l'époque pour les enfants s'ils ont de
bonnes da
il y aura peut-être encore autre chose
je suis aimerait une surprise
est-ce que vous sortiez dans la tranche
show d'avaler des bouteilles cassées
pour amuser ses dames rira bien qui rira
le dernier
je continue à trouver d'une piété folle
mais au diable et et
je ne dois pas votre nouvel ami monsieur
macha watts pelli devait être parano
fils le maroufle avec le voilà
pour ce
mois ci revenait je vous ai promis une
surprise vous allez la voir et ils
deviennent smart charmant que cela
j'avoue que j'éprouve le soin de ma côté
dit c'est ce que tu m'as promis nous
unit tous et l auvergne avec une balle
ou encore les petits malins
pensez vous monsieur ce sont quoi mettre
assis et devant est bel
et bien
le gascon cité par les époux ce soir ce
soir à catane
[Rires]
et
bms
et non c'est faux c'est la cua a non le
l'autre et l'autre était content comme
ça et puis gros scooter
elles ont fait un manchon ce matin et
oui j'ai menti eamon humaine tout seule
fille que c'est l'excellent et que ce n
est
jamais trop brouillons mois jean py plus
c'est pas lui en temps à mons on se fait
pas mes amis je suis nous prouve t'as
jamais petit mensonge il ne vaut souvent
mieux tu des pinces vérité exemple mais
les voix
madame tenez votre couturière vous à
vagues hautes et comme la sorcière de
mahbès en effet de l'épaisse d'éviter la
contrée preuve
belda av
les lycées les roses n'en finirons dont
jamais de se jouer pour votre vrai
visage de m toujours ça remet en
effet du mensonge à la monte en place
pour la contre lens
ali bongo faisait
le fait qu'on a fait paris brembo des
vraiment ces gens m'ont dit qu'elles
étaient
mais je savais que sa vie sur cette
scène de charmant acteur que l'on ne
trouverait pas meilleure
il faut talent sous élégant qui
s'entraident et sèment leurs mets tes
vieux qu'elle manomètres époque et
habiba incognito
[Musique]
mais aussi des gars de mort messieurs je
vous dis ma vie minutes est ce que vous
savez que vous appelez pour notre scène
de chaque manceau d'un délicieux peintre
demeure
ils sont un talent et train selon qui
vous ont à peine qui font tout eux la
bhl que molière et corgnet
absolument pas vraiment quelque chose
d'énorme
a rien donné mais aussi calmement mais
mes genoux je vais vous dire les
ruminants oui vraiment c'est japon
qu'elle fait en parfaite avait vraiment
mais vraiment c'est charmant comme
google ad 1
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs
la pièce qui nous venons de jouer et de
eugène labiche
la musique originale des darbyshire
les décors sont de roger hart
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les costumes de donald le cambouis
allez
aussi se chauffe eau
daniel doré
dans ce ruisseau
mais maurice risch
la migros fait et de jean le poulain
[Musique]